well the government has said that they
want to look at
testing but they were saying that two
weeks ago when the spanish crisis
happened but we've seen nothing from the
government since then
and time is ticking had we moved at the
time of the spanish crisis
then we could have avoided the french
crisis last weekend
and avoided the risk of passengers
having to go into quarantine
when they could have had an alternative
of being tested here at the airport
now this is something that is being
carried out in other countries
in germany in iceland they have either
a test after one day three days or five
days
but in britain we're still imposing a
14-day quarantine on anyone coming from
a high-risk country
we need to do better than this if we are
going to
rebuild our economy as an
outward-looking trading nation
uh but you are i'm assuming in regular
contact with the department of transport
if this system is such a good idea why
haven't they given you the green light
so far
well this is a question for government
as a whole this is something for number
10 to really get a grip on and give us
the green light to go ahead with testing
testing is a very good way of making
sure that people don't have covid
it's what we rely on with the nhs
workers and if it's good enough for the
nhs it should be good enough
for visitors to this country to start to
get people traveling again
and to help to rebuild the economy and
this isn't just about people going
home when you speak to those the
department of transport what kind of
reaction are you getting
what's the mood music to your idea
well the department of transport i think
is very keen that this should happen but
this is not their decision this is a
cross-government
decision and if this is a question for
number 10
to get a grip of our border policy
to make sure that business can start
flowing again it is
our exports from the uk that travel on
passenger planes from heathrow actually
40 percent of all the uk's exports go on
passenger planes from pedro
but if those planes can't fly because
people can't
uh travel on them then our exports are
grounded
this is holding back the recovery of the
uk economy
and putting thousands and thousands of
jobs at risk and the government needs to
act now
to allow testing as an alternative to
quarantine so we can get the economy
kick-started
who within the aviation sector is
backing your plan
everyone in the aviation sector is
backing the plan and as are
lots of businesses as well they want to
see uh the economy getting started again
and aviation is the lifeblood of the uk
economy with so many
not just physical exports traveling on
planes but services too
people want to be able to reopen our
borders but do it in a safe way and
testing is a good alternative
it's being used in other european
countries it is becoming the norm
but the uk having started well by
introducing
the risk-based measures of green amber
and red countries
has now fallen behind and we need to
move quickly to get people
moving through uh through the uk again
to help to recover the uk economy
the problem is though it's confidence
isn't it of passengers it's not just a
quarantine that's stopping people from
flying it's the feeling of being safe on
board or in an airport and not
contracting the virus i mean this plan
doesn't tackle that does it
well actually we have a lot of
confidence from passengers you'll see
behind me
the where people can fly they do fly
there's a lot of appetites to travel
around the world
a lot of people wanting to visit friends
and relatives
as well as to go on business what is
holding them back is the ability to go
to
the markets they want to get to the the
uh relaxation of quarantine measures
only applied to 30 percent of the
countries that we fly to
and that means that 70 of our markets
are still closed to us and they're
really important markets such as the
united states
and as we think of britain's future
outside of the european union
we need to be trading with places like
the us and canada and singapore
all of which are quarantined at the
moment that needs to change if we're
going to rebuild the uk economy
and that means moving to testing as
other european competitors are doing
rather than imposing a 14-day quarantine
which
stops people flying altogether